the high-water mark may already be  behind them but the danger has far from  subsided on silhoue Sea Island at least  3,000 people were forced to leave their  homes as rivers burst their banks and  Hill sites gave way under the heavy  rains flooding is hardly a rarity here  during monsoon season but still  residents say they were caught unawares  the water started to rise here but then  suddenly a nearby river burst its banks  after ten minutes the water was already  a meter and a half high we didn't expect  it at all emergency shelters have been  erected in local mosques the military  has been deployed throughout the island  their first challenge keeping evacuees  warm and fed they're starving they're  kids asking for milk and food it's hard  to get to them rescuers continue to pull  people from the water throughout the  island however with dozens missing and  many villages still under water they  warned that the number of the Dead will  continue to rise  you